Erin Andrews speaks out for the first
time on TV since winning her peeping tom
lawsuit I just I want to thank everybody
the TV personality was a guest on Jimmy
Kimmel Live Wednesday her first public
appearance since being awarded 55
million dollars in her peeping tom hotel
lawsuit Andrew smiled as she expressed
her gratitude this is kind of Maya might
come out of hiding so thank you why
would I not want to be here I just I
want to thank everybody there were so
many people that actually reached out
and all over the world really and
cornish the 37 year old has seemingly
put the past behind her and is looking
forward to co-hosting next week season
premiere of dancing with the stars
Andrew shared this unique spoiler about
contestant Geraldo Rivera who she says
will channel his work as a reporter in
the 80s into his first routine did you
ever know about this mystery mysterious
vault of Al Capone that Geraldo did and
I guess he said he's the punchline of it
now they opened it up it's a live to our
event i guess the ratings were like off
the charts yeah and there was like a
stop sign it there's nothing in there
yeah there will be a vault the season
premiere for Geraldo and a very sexy
edit ah comes out of it